sind denn die kurzarbeiter von heute die
arbeitslosen von morgen
ja das ist die 100.000 euro frage die
wir zu verantworten haben ich glaube ich
dass das alles arbeitslose werden das
ist ja im grunde genommen
die ganze geschichte die hinter der
kurzarbeit steckt die hoffnung dass die
wieder auf ihren arbeitsplatz zurück er
würde das nicht passieren dann war
dieses ganze diese ganze aufwand mit der
kurzarbeit im grunde genommen für die
katzen gehören nicht besser dastehen als
die länder die von vornherein gar keine
kurzarbeit vorgesehen haben
ich glaube aber nach trotzdem dass es zu
überlegen in arbeitslosigkeit
kommentiert das hängt natürlich von dem
verlauf der pandemie aber wir haben
einige branchen gastronomie
beispielsweise hotellerie und ähnliche
die nach wie vor auch selbst wenn die
nachfrage der kunden wieder zurückkehren
würde der probleme haben weil sie eben
zum beispiel abstandsgebot einhalten
müssen und gar nicht mit voller
kapazität mit voller auslastung arbeiten
können und viele davon werden das
wirtschaftlich auf die dauer nicht
darstellen können werden
möglicherweise schließen müssen oder
eben mit einer verringerten kapazität
arbeiten müssen was eben auch weiß dass
viele menschen viele kellner dann auch
zum beispiel ihren arbeitsplatz
verlieren könnten
rettet den kurz arbeitet wirklich jeden
job nein jeden job nicht aber die
hoffnung ist eben dass wir schneller und
besser aus der krise wieder herauskommen
weil für den fall wo die nachfrage
insgesamt wieder ansteigt und da haben
wir jetzt leicht tat erste zarte
anzeichen dafür darf sind die genau für
den job passenden arbeitnehmer ohne
größere zeitliche verzögerung zur
verfügung die stelle zur verfügung und
müssen nicht erst aufwendig auf dem
arbeitsmarkt neu rekrutiert werden und
das ist der große vorteil bei der bei
der kurzarbeit aber das bringt natürlich
nur wenn tatsächlich diese arbeitskräfte
nachfrage der betriebe entsprechend
ansteigt und aus der kurzarbeit wieder
in den job hinein in eine bewegung
stattfindet glauben sie dass wir die
drei-millionen-grenze an arbeitslosen
knacken werden und wenn ja wann
das ist sehr knapp derzeit also unsere
projektionen
er gibt der zeit dass wir im dezember
die drei millionen grenze überschreiten
werden allerdings nur knapp der
jahresdurchschnitt für das jahr 2020 für
die anzahl der arbeitslosen liegt bei
ungefähr 2,8 millionen und welche folgen
hat dann diese hohe arbeitslosigkeit
auch für die sozialsysteme wie zum
beispiel die rentenkasse die
sozialsysteme werden
gold im grunde genommen beeinträchtigt
die arbeitslosenversicherung natürlich
ganz besonders weil die erhöhte kosten
hat zum einen und zum anderen natürlich
verminderte beitragseinnahmen wenn
andere widerum möglicherweise
einschnitte bei den beitragseinnahmen im
falle der kurzarbeit wird das ja zum
teil daneben kompensiert durch die durch
das kurzarbeitergeld aber trotzdem muss
man sich darauf einstellen dass eben
auch die masse die man verteilen kann
über die sozialversicherungssysteme
nicht unbedingt sehr viel größer wird
immer besser
dieser krise